[Aplausos]
[Música]
una pregunta de qué marca es vuestro
teléfono móvil
supongo que muchos de vosotros tal vez
la mayoría responderéis que apple
samsung o huawei o suave o como se diga
hawi o wayne y wii
[Música]
como lo sé pues no se trata de ningún
truco de magia ni nada por el estilo
simplemente lo sé porque año tras año
estas tres empresas lideran las ventas
en el mercado mundial de teléfonos
móviles entre las tres venden
aproximadamente la mitad de todos los
smartphones que se venden en el mundo
hablamos de un mercado gigantesco se
calcula que en 2018 el número de
usuarios de smartphones alcanza la
brutal cifra de 3 mil millones de
personas china encabeza la lista de más
usuarios a nivel mundial casi 780
millones de chinos utilizan en su día a
día un smartphone y no sólo eso el
gigante chino también se ha convertido
en un actor fundamental en la industria
por ejemplo es el país de origen de
algunos de los mayores fabricantes de
smartphones de todo el planeta hablamos
de empresas como huawei o zte pues bien
sabéis donde se fabrican estos
dispositivos exacto en la ciudad de
shenzhen más conocida como el silicon
valley chino os hemos hablado ya de este
increíble lugar en varios vídeos y si
estás suscrito a visual polític no hará
falta que te recuerde que en apenas 40
años shenzhen pasó de ser una pequeña
localidad pesquera a convertirse en una
mega urbe especializada en la alta
tecnología en uno de los lugares que más
crecen de todo el planeta de todas
formas por si acaso sois nuevos por aquí
en la descripción os dejo el enlace a
varios vídeos
[Música]
y no sólo se trata de las empresas más
grandes como el caso de huawei las
propias apple o samsung trabajan con un
montón de proveedores de esta ciudad
es decir prácticamente todos nosotros de
una forma u otra estamos relacionados
con shenzhen utilizamos los productos de
esta ciudad constantemente todos los
días y a todas horas
en otras palabras todos tenemos un poco
de shenzhen en nuestras manos
ahora bien exactamente como se produjo
esta enorme transformación es un caso
único en el mundo y la pregunta más
importante qué diantres tiene que ver
shenzhen con honduras uno de los países
más pobres de américa e incluso del
mundo atentos a la semilla del cambio
[Música]
pues lo hemos contado aquí en visual
política a comienzos de los años 80 el
entonces presidente chino deng xiaoping
creó una zona económica especial en la
frontera con hong kong shenzhen fue la
primera de muchas que más tarde se
abrirían a lo largo y ancho de toda
china ahora bien un momento hay una
pregunta que seguro muchos os estáis
haciendo que es exactamente una zona
económica especial
[Música]
pues amigos básicamente una zona
económica especial es un área geográfica
delimitada dentro de un país donde las
normas para hacer negocios son
diferentes por lo general mucho menos
restrictivas que las del resto del país
[Música]
las zonas económicas especiales se
diseñaron como una forma de impulsar el
comercio y la inversión tienen límites
geográficos claros normas y regulaciones
diferentes un sistema administrativo
propio en definitiva hablamos de
territorios completamente orientados a
los negocios a la producción y a la
inversión por así decirlo en el caso de
china estos lugares se convirtieron en
algo así como refugios capitalistas en
pleno modelo socialista
y sabéis que fueron un enorme éxito la
apertura de estas zonas económicas
atrajo un enorme volumen de inversión
tanto de capital chino como extranjero
toda esa inversión atrajo a miles de
inmigrantes e impulsó la construcción de
fábricas y viviendas para mediados de la
década de los 90 shenzhen ya tenía 3
millones de habitantes y una economía
extraordinariamente dinámica
y el proceso continuo hasta nuestros
días y la actualidad se encuenta con 12
millones de residentes que ascienden a
15 millones durante la temporada de
verano y otoño cuando las fábricas
trabajan a destajo para atender la
enorme demanda de regalos electrónicos
en navidad santa claus amigos no puede
olvidarse de los smartphones los drones
y todos los cachivaches de última
generación que durante las navidades se
entregan como si no hubiera mañana
ahora bien ni mucho menos china ha sido
el único país en apostar por este modelo
otro ejemplo del libro lo podemos
encontrar en los emiratos árabes unidos-
especialmente en el emirato de dubai
seguro que lo sabéis porque también os
lo hemos contado en varias ocasiones en
este canal hablamos por ejemplo de jebel
ali o del centro financiero de dubai
este último no solo tiene sus propias
regulaciones sino que incluso cuenta con
sus propios tribunales además por
supuesto de poca burocracia pocos
impuestos mucha seguridad jurídica y
procedimientos sencillos para hacer
negocios
qué más se puede pedir amigos el caso es
que la estrategia para diversificar la
economía más allá del petróleo se basó
fundamentalmente en estas zonas
económicas especiales que hoy suman más
de 45 en todo el país
el resultado consiguieron que los
emiratos tuvieran desde 1980 el mayor
crecimiento económico de toda la región
durante este tiempo su pib se ha
multiplicado ni más ni menos que por 10
ahora bien qué quiere decir esto que por
el mero hecho de abrir zonas económicas
especiales el éxito está asegurado pues
amigos ni muchísimo menos para que una
zona económica especial realmente
funcione tiene que cumplir con algunos
requisitos gestionarse con plena
autonomía tener buenas infraestructuras
mucha seguridad jurídica mucha libertad
económica impuestos cometidos poca
burocracia y terreno suficiente para
crecer
hasta el momento hemos visto dos casos
de éxito china y emiratos pero podemos
encontrar algún caso de fracaso pues si
en cierto modo la india ha sido
históricamente un ejemplo a no seguir
[Música]
veréis me explico la india estableció
sus primeras zonas económicas especiales
ni más ni menos que en la década de los
60 por tanto mucho antes que china de
hecho podría ser considerada una pionera
en todo este tema sin embargo en el año
2000 apenas había siete zonas operando
en todo el país con un resultado mucho
muchísimo más discreto que los del
ejemplo chino porque pues porque amigos
estas zonas no eliminaban la burocracia
no funcionaban con autonomía estaban muy
limitadas en cuanto a espacio y operaban
con muchas muchísimas restricciones
vamos que más que zonas económicas
especiales eran una auténtica castaña
creo que ahora podemos entender mejor
por qué china ha crecido mucho más que
la india durante las últimas décadas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ahora bien un momento llegados a este
punto creo que hay una pregunta que
muchos os estáis haciendo
alberto qué diantres tiene que ver todo
esto con honduras pues atentos
[Música]
el experimento hondureño realidad o
ficción amigos de visual político las
zonas económicas especiales son muy
populares en el mundo del comercio
internacional desde los 80 su número ha
crecido como la espuma
y en 1986 la organización internacional
del trabajo reportaba 176 zonas en 47
países en el año 2006 ya eran más de
3.500 en 130 países actualmente en
latinoamérica se estima que hay más de
300 zonas económicas especiales más de
la mitad se encuentran en centroamérica
claro que como os podéis imaginar con
unas condiciones mucho más limitadas que
en el caso chino ya sabéis a los
gobiernos latinos les encanta
controlarlo todo o al menos intentarlo
sin embargo amigos hay un país que ha
puesto sobre la mesa un plan para
aparentemente cambiar esta situación y
ese país es honduras
honduras es uno de los países más pobres
de toda la región es un país donde la
inmensa mayor parte de la población vive
en condiciones de pobreza un país que
tiene tasas de violencia enormes y donde
cada año decenas y decenas de miles de
personas intentan escapar en busca de
una vida mejor generalmente dirigiéndose
a los eeuu
tengo que intentarlo una nueva caravana
de inmigrantes sale de honduras y se
dirige a los eeuu violencias oscurecen
la vida en honduras pues amigos durante
los últimos años honduras ha presentado
una ingeniosa estrategia para darle la
vuelta a esta situación un plan en el
que ha jugado un papel destacado el
economista estadounidense paul romer
premio nobel de economía en 2018 la
estrategia consiste en crear a lo largo
y ancho de todo el país las conocidas
como zonas de empleo y desarrollo
económico ahora bien que son exactamente
estas cede pues amigos en la misma línea
de lo que os hemos contado como en
honduras las cosas no funcionan las
cedes son una especie de experimento
para que la actividad económica pueda
empezar a crecer desde cero en algunas
zonas del país es decir las cds serían
zonas del territorio nacional hondureño
que contarían con una regulación
especial e instituciones propias para
garantizar la seguridad tanto física
como jurídica así como la facilidad para
hacer negocios como todo empezaría desde
cero
cambiar de golpe todo el sistema
nacional algo que se antoja por todos
los intereses existentes como una misión
imposible la idea es que estas cde
consiguieran atraer mucha inversión y
crear muchísimos empleos de tal forma
que lograran ser un revulsivo para el
resto del país tal y como ocurrió con
las zonas económicas especiales de china
la sede tendrían personalidad jurídica
propia se administrarían de forma
autónoma y estarían autorizadas a
establecer sus propias políticas y
normativas y no sólo eso también
contarían con su propia policía sus
propios tribunales independientes e
incluso operarían bajo la tradición del
derecho anglosajón lo que se conoce como
la common law
[Música]
además amigos la propiedad del suelo de
estas zonas sería propiedad del estado
pero su administración correría a cargo
de las propias cb que establecerían
claramente el método o los pasos a
seguir para acceder y desarrollar ese
suelo todo en un marco de competencia
para que las empresas y los inversores
cuenten con el suelo necesario para sus
proyectos y no se enfrenten a pesadas
regulaciones urbanísticas capaces de
frenar el desarrollo
de esta forma cada zona especial podría
especializarse en actividades diferentes
u organizarse de distinta manera para no
solo competir con el resto del mundo
sino también para competir entre sí algo
que obligaría a sus administradores a
copiar y mejorar las mejores políticas
existentes para atraer inversión atraer
talento y en definitiva impulsar el
desarrollo del país
inteligente verdad podemos imaginar
centros financieros centros logísticos
zonas turísticas especiales e incluso
ciudades autónomas un momento ciudades
autónomas pues si habéis escuchado bien
porque limitar estas zonas especiales
sólo a las empresas por qué no probar a
construir modelos de convivencia que
puedan funcionar mejor que el desastre
que se vive hoy en honduras
es lo que se conoce como fruit cities de
las que ya os adelanto a hablaremos aquí
en visual político largo y tendido así
que no olvidéis suscribiros y darle a la
campanita para estar al tanto de todos
nuestros nuevos vídeos
claro que antes de lanzar las campanas
al vuelo
todo esto amigos puede parecernos un
proyecto muy pero que muy atractivo pero
nos sorprende que sea precisamente la
élite política hondureña la que esté
liderando este proceso no os genera
ninguna sospecha
el hermano del presidente hondureño
arrestado en miami está acusado de
tráfico de drogas pues eso es lo que en
cierto modo piensa el propio paul romer
que ha tomado cierta distancia de este
proyecto bueno mejor dicho ha escapado
corriendo porque pues porque tiene la
impresión de que la élite hondureña lo
que realmente quiere no es precisamente
promover la competencia y la inversión
sino tener un territorio que solo les
favorezca a ellos
han aprobado una nueva ley que cruza mi
línea roja esta ley elimina toda
posibilidad de responsabilidad electoral
para las personas que dirigen las zonas
esto no estaba la ley que apoye no puedo
decir si lo que estamos viendo es una
farsa o una tragedia podría terminar
siendo una farsa porque no puedo
imaginar que un inversionista reflexivo
entre invertir en estas circunstancias
en un lugar controlado por una
aristocracia de amigos paul romer
y no ha sido ni mucho menos el único la
evolución que ha seguido este proyecto
genera muchas dudas incluso existe la
sospecha de que todas estas cd
terminarán siendo simplemente un
instrumento para que los oligarcas de
siempre se apoderen de más partes del
país y encima puedan hacer y deshacer a
su completo antojo vamos todo un refugio
para narcos y oligarcas de todo tipo la
falta de transparencia y los conflictos
sociales causados no parecen reflejar la
idea de un gobierno que busca impulsar
el desarrollo
[Música]
y es por todo esto por lo que de la
ilusión inicial se ha pasado al
desencanto y las sospechas por así
decirlo estaríamos ante una idea
fantástica pero con una ejecución pésima
y unos objetivos aún peores amigos el
caso es que estas sedes están
proyectadas para arrancar a finales de
2019 claro sí consiguieron consolidarse
y salir adelante respetando el espíritu
de libertad competencia e igualdad de
oportunidades del concepto de zonas
económicas especiales podríamos estar
ante un cambio de rumbo total para
honduras pero si es difícil ser
optimistas en este caso en fin la
pregunta es realmente honduras apostará
y conseguirás sacar adelante un modelo
de cds plenamente autónoma sin
intromisión de los políticos lograr a
honduras convertirse en la shenzhen de
centroamérica o se convertirá en otro
caso fallido como la india déjame tu
respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta si este vídeo te
resultado interesante no dejes de darle
al botón de like un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]